DIMINISHED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID THE RIGHT
THING BY WALKING AWAY FROM THE
VIETNAM SUMMIT WITHOUT GIVING IN
TO KIM'S DEMANDS FOR SANCTIONS
RELIEF.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO A FORMER
NORTH KOREA OFFICIAL.
HIS COMMENTS PUT A POSITIVE SPIN
ON THE ABRUPT END TO THE
CONFERENCE.
HERE'S THE STORY.
>> KIM JONG-UN MEETING WITH TOP
VIETNAM OFFICIALS A DAY AFTER
THE NORTH KOREA LEADER SUMMIT
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP IN HANOI
BROKE DOWN.
SECRETARY OF STATE POMPEO STILL
SOUNDED POSITIVE.
>> WE ARE ANXIOUS TO GET BACK TO
THE TABLE TO CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION THAT WILL LEAD TO
PEACE AND STABILITY AND A BETTER
LIFE FOR THE NORTH KOREA PEOPLE
AND A LOWER THREAT WITH A
DENUCLEARIZATION OF NORTH KOREA.
>> MY ADMINISTRATION WILL
COMMUNICATE WITH THE UNITED
STATES AND NORTH KOREA TO HELP
THEIR TALKS REACH A COMPLETE
SETTLEMENT.
>> ACCORDING TO THE NORTH KOREA
CLEAR DIPLOMAT AND DEFECTOR HO,
SPEAKING WITH FOX NEWS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS CORRECT IN
REJECTING THE DEMAND BY THE
NORTH TO LIFT SANCTIONS FOR
SHUTTING DOWN JUST 1 NUCLEAR
FACILITY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS RIGHT.
>> HE SAID TRUMP WAS ALSO RIGHT
WHEN HE SINGLED OUT OTHER SITES
FOR KIM TO DISMANTLE.
THE MAN WHO LIVES WITH GUARDS
UNDER ASSASSINATION THREATS IN
SEOUL, SAID AS LONG AS THE
MERCILESS KIM JONG-UN IS IN
POWER THE BEST PRESIDENT TRUMP
CAN DO IS CONTAIN THE NUCLEAR
EVIL.
>> NUCLEAR WEAPONS IS THE LAST
THING KIM JONG-UN IS RELY ON TO
CONTINUE HIS CONTROL OF NORTH
KOREA.
>> DO YOU THINK HE WOULD EVER
GIVE UP THE NUCLEAR WEAPONS?
>> NO.
>> NOT AT ALL?
>> NOT AT ALL.
>> HE SAID HE IS POSITIVE ABOUT
NORTH KOREA'S FUTURE WITH MORE
INFORMATION AND CHANGES AMONG
THE PEOPLE.
THE CURRENT SYSTEM AND ITS
LEADER CAN'T LAST.
THAT CHANGE COULD TAKE YEARS.